good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is believe over the you Gary Vaynerchuk
[Music]
sometimes a lot of people may try a new
initiative and then they don't get an
immediate reaction and they think it's a
failure okay I wanna go back to your
YouTube videos with the Wine Library you
know you had so much content out there
how did you stick in there how did you
keep yourself motivated because I
believe in my strategies and I'm patient
like all great stuff especially when
you're innovating doesn't happen right
away this notion that like Oh Gary I
tried it I spent five hundred bucks on
Facebook Ads it doesn't work well what
if your video sucked what if your
product and service sucks I I tend to do
things that are very early that has been
my career you I when I do things I
believe in them I stick with them based
on intuition even though for 18 months
nobody watched my wine videos at all I
knew it was right I was right there's
been things I've done that I've jumped
off of very quickly I started to Gary v
app V chat ve like WeChat that was funny
for my fans great CRM one on one didn't
feel right after a week or two spend
plenty money building it knew it stopped
it after you know a couple months Wine
Library TV five years every day YouTube
decided to change at the daily grape
insular app you could buy stuff
subscription for reviews it was a lot of
fun only did it for five months stopped
it because I didn't feel right anymore
it's always hard to know when to jump
off something new but I find that people
don't believe in what they're doing they
hear o guru yeah and they do it
begrudgingly cuz their boss wants them
to or they're like well Gary's right a
lot so let me do it but they don't
believe it and so then they jump they're
looking for knows instead of yeses
everything I do every business
development every event I do every time
I try new marketing tactics or sales
tactic I'm looking for the yes right I'm
looking for the yes and if the
no punches me will then on my crap then
no punched me I believe the majority of
people when they try new tactics are
looking for the know mm-hmm and you're
gonna getting a lot of subtle knows
immediately right and so I think that's
why that happens if you have to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple so it would be like
a little beacon pay believe nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and
Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details